anger and frustration spilled to the
streets
protesters in freetown and other syrian
union cities wanted their voices heard
[Music]
we do not have freedom of speech there's
no respect for us the women and our
economy is down down down and the cost
of living is very high because of it we
are suffering
it didn't end well
several people were killed including
members of the security forces when
demonstrators and the police clashed it
revived images from the country's bloody
civil war in the nineties
the president tweeted saying
as a government we have the
responsibility to protect every citizen
of sierra leone what happened today was
unfortunate and will be fully
investigated i urge all sierra leoneans
to be calm
the government also imposed a nationwide
curfew
government here by
declares a nationwide coffee with effect
from today
wednesday 10th august 2022 commencing at
3pm
while it's unknown whether the wave of
protests will continue the united
nations expressed serious concerns over
the violence so that the us while france
urged its citizens not to travel to
sierra leone
ali hashim al-jazeera